you and me breaking down there the big
fight yeah breaking down big events you
know an idea like if I didn't work for
the UFC I would love to go there and
just like cover the weigh-ins as like a
spectator but as as unfiltered no
production and me just talking sure yeah
yes like I don't like doing the
weigh-ins stressful I try to pronounce
people's names P otra Yan like what
there couldn't be a worse job for me if
you ask me it pronounce everyone's names
correctly some of these Russian cats
their names are off the charts and it's
at this time Russians G and a Z but you
gotta use a why not to say it like a why
like what not for me what is the name
yeah I have to write it out phonetically
how much long do you think you'd do that
I don't know just between me and you no
one's listening
no one's listening I don't know I do
enjoy ever thought about it yes all the
time
well why I cut way back because first of
all I was doing too many of them at one
point time I was doing 24 a year was way
too many it was like half a year I was
half the weekends in the air I was
flying somewhere to go to the UFC but
that's when you did international as
well yeah yeah I was too much and that
was before the UFC really they started
adding a bunch of people yeah it took a
lot of the weight off me
yeah I'm sad they got rid of Jimmy Smith
I think Jimmy Smith is really good I
think he's really good but sometimes
it's just not a fit like I didn't see I
didn't find him and maybe he didn't get
his fair shot I think he's one of the
best commentators in the world but it
never felt right maybe because he was it
he didn't get to do it enough he's
brilliant at his job but there was that
I just didn't it never felt right to me
he was like watching Joe Montana play
for the Chiefs well I'm selfish he's my
friend I was happy he was there I think
he's really good I love Jimmy I'm not
saying I think he's great I think he's
been gone since whoever finds them can
be lucky but it never like the writing
was on the wall cuz you would see DC
who's amazing and I see Paul Felder
who's amazing that Dominick Cruz yeah
Michael Bisbing and thing of course
Jimmy's not gonna have a job
like they're gonna use they in-house
guys then the direction they're going
yeah
so I wonder if he could do play-by-play
you know like when the ones a Nanak
doesn't want to do and anak does all
that hey anak go home to your kids don't
you have like seven dollars go home to
your [ __ ] kids Jon knows I love him
but I see him at Brazil post like two
days sleep you know been on the road 19
days in a row like you go home bro you
can't he's he's the best he's really
good there's not a better commentating
team in the history of combat sports
when it's you DC and John annek that's
the best it's fun to fun
DC's himself yeah one of the best
fighters of all time
John X very [ __ ] good he's a
brilliant dude and then you do your
thing and that's he saw DC's so loose
too like he makes it silly he's a
special dude like when when Rose knocked
out
Yoani and Jay check he's like thug rows
what you want thug rows you can't care
you can't pay for that no that's natural
that's yeah no you either got it he
don't he has it yeah that's his future
man yeah that's his future
yeah well that's why everybody kind of
wants him to retire you know that's why
I think his family's kind of pushing for
him to retire and I knock crazy Bob cook
he's like I'd be happy for retired right
now I and I don't think the u.s. he's
gonna let him retire without facing John
John's the heavyweight division he
certainly can retire if he decides to
mm-hmm
not happening you don't think so nope
they're gonna throw that big me sit down
and you sit down make a deal with the
devil Nike think about your time very
cool here's the thing we're gonna pay
you this much to fight this monster
they're gonna give out that pantego yep
I'm gonna push that piece of paper cross
hands gonna go through my return what is
it just look at me a favor just look at
this that number red strip steak house
in Vegas we're talking about two million
pay-per-view buys and this is what you
would get set for life
he's probably set for left already ah he
made four million dollars with Derrick
Lewis they're not sad only yourself who
knows how much you made for Steve Bay
who knows how much he made I mean let's
say after taxes ten million in the bank
does that set no how do you live oh you
weren't gold watch bro dude that's not
that crazy Louie CK has a joke and his
uh his newest set about buying a cold
one daddy what's he say couldn't be more
upset yeah it's a gold Rolex the [ __ ]
gold Rolex me yeah so I'm saying ten
million dollars isn't gonna last for you
YouTube that was ten million with Laxmi
I'm not that crazy everyone thinks I'm
okay how long would it last for the rest
of your life
ten million I'd be set with my
investment stuff like that buy property
I'd be I'd be panic and count well don't
get me wrong I wouldn't stop working you
know I'm saying if you wanted to stop
working if you wanted I don't know do
you have you ever thought about have you
ever put a number if I get here I can
chill out and like I don't need to do I
have seventeen podcasts I don't need to
do all that work I don't need to do mind
sets a week at you know the comic stores
I want to get good I know but I'm what
if I want to get a hundred percent if I
only get a podcast and do that if I want
to get it but there has to be some
material level financially where I can
get to rock you know I can chill out on
this but I'm not I'm not built that way
every morning I wake up like ah [ __ ] man
we ready to get going better get going I
don't I don't think about retiring
because I like what I do
so I don't think I don't think like oh I
need to have X amount of money in the
bank so I'm not going to do this very
much long I'm not saying retiring I'm
saying maybe cut back on all the [ __ ]
you do mmm I like all that stuff I think
it keeps me from going crazy too I think
being active keeps me from losing my
marbles yeah if I just just around the
house just following with my demons
oppressed I don't think I'd ever get
depressed really no I get depressed from
that if I'm not busy if I'm with my son
I'm good but you leave me alone now I'm
like a gremlin after men
don't leave me alone man I don't like
being all by myself all the time well I
have so many different interests that
I've sort of one of the patterns that
I've picked up my whole life is that I
like to do I find things that I like to
do and I do them as much as I can I
would I mean I have so many different
things whether it's archery or martial
arts or I would I've joined the [ __ ]
pro pool tour I would do some C but
everything you're talking about it would
you want to hear good about to those
you're doing that with friends like so
your friends are the best in the world
at those things you just mentioned
that's handed that helps having well
yeah if you were alone with no friends
that [ __ ] is very that's when I can get
a little dark if you leave me like that
my brother goes on the road to me all
the time I I've done tons of dates and
when he's not with me I'm in that room
all by myself yeah for like three or
four days like oh I'm not I'm not happy
man I'm not doing well I don't know I
try so many talks on about but I don't
know that is a depressing thing when
you're alone on the road I used to do
those gigs on the road with no opening
act like way back in the day and we work
with a local guy and it was just not
fine if the local guy was cool it was
great we had a good old time and it was
fun
I hope and you know I like everybody but
if if I'm all set on friends so if
you're not my group I don't want to
spend time like I'm not gonna go to eat
with you I'm like I'll see you out see
at the venue man like I don't want to
get to know each other
anybody no no not really your books
closed it's a lot of energy man I talk
for a living so if you didn't have to
work ever again what would you do with
your time like what if say you know you
hit the lottery you won 500 billion
dollars never after work again I'd still
do stand-up in podcasting really
guaranteed yeah if I'm not busy like I
like been stupid busy like I didn't like
you don't see you and I have a new
podcast I didn't you do that I already
have my show on Showtime but yet you did
need to do that because I love doing
well it's not for financial work